عام 20 22 عام وظيفي او عامل مسار المهني
كما يطلق عليه موقع فورس عام شهد اكبر
التغييرات في النظام الوظيفي بعد عامين
قاسيين بفعل الوباء واثاره السلبيه على
الناس هذا الموظفون حول العالم نظرتهم لما
يريدونه في مكان العمل الموظفون يريدون
الشروط عمل مريحه ساعات مريضه وسط
احتجاجات عماليه في دول عده لرفع الاجور
مع موجه التضخم التي تضرب العالم في
الولايات المتحده شهدنا اربعه ملايين
استقاله كل شهر بين يناير واكتوبر خلال
للعام الجاري وهي نسبه اعلى بكثير من
مستويات ما قبلنا
وشاهدنا ايضا شركات تكنولوجيا عالميه
تتخلى عن خدمات الاف من موظفيها في يوم
وليله والتوتر في فرنسا
وقلص الدول ومنها مدن عربيه ايام الدوام
الاسبوعيه الى اربعه ايام لتحفيز الموظ
على الانتاجيه وهو ما اختبرته الشركات
البريطانيه ايضا على مدار سته اشهر
الماضيه
ومن العراق سالنا ما هو القرار الوظيفي
الذي ستتخذونه للعام القادم
[موسيقى]
طبعا انا ما احب غير اييي عملي من صغري
وانا على هاي المصلحه نفسها
اليوم صعبه تيجي بعد هذا العمر كله تيجي
تغير مصلحتك الغير مصلحه ما تقدر لان انت
تعودت وفتحت عينك على هذه المصلحه حاليا
وظيفه حلوه ومرتاح فيها الصراحه ما فضل
لانه
ما هو عندي شغل الاعلام خصوصا في التخصص
العلاقات العامه شيء حلو ومرتب اللي تتكون
علاقتك مع انت شخصيه من فنانين او مسؤولين
او هالامور فانا افضل يعني ابقى على
وظيفتي بصراحه كل انسان باي مهنه كانت
يشتغل هيك ويعمل بها في سلبيات وفي
ايجابيات
بحكم العمل اللي همم
بس الحمد لله والشكر انا بالنسبه لي يعني
همم
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه انا متقاعد حاليا متقاعد لكنه
العمل موجود والعمل ما ينتهي بالنسبه الي
شخصيا لان انا عندي اهتمام عبد الحقيقه
اهتمامات ادبيه كتابه الشغل
صار لي لمده اربع سنوات او تقريبا من بعد
الاعداديه
حتى بالجامعه انه انا اشتغل على انه يكون
مصور وانترنت
شغلي واغير اختصاصي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم لنا من جده مستشار تطوير القيادي
والاعمال
التقرير يعني السنه اللي فاتت كانت اكثر
السنه تقلبات الوظيفيه وتغيرات وظيفيه
اولا كيف يقيم الموظف سنه التوظيفيه
بدي اقدم شيء للعالم بكل انسان
من انسان
من عشره سنوات
من الوظائف اللي دخلت فيها من الاعمال
والمشاريع اللي دخل فيها فشلت الى ان ما
بقول صدفه الى ان وجدت نفسي في المكان
اللي انا فيه
تقرير واحد قال انا في نفس الوظيفه لكن
انت تعودت هذه المصيبه يعني اذا انت مو
مجالك
طب انت ممكن تكتشف مجالك الي انت تحبه
وتستمتع فيه الشخص الثاني في التقرير اللي
حابه العلاقات العامه يقول لك هذا انا
حابه لانه هذا انسان عنده شيء اسمه ذكاء
اجتماعي هو الحب يكون بين الناس
في ناس ما يحبوا الناس في ناس انت في ناس
عندهم بكاء شخص الشخص اللي قال لك انا
متقاعد بس ما ما وقفت عمل لانه عند
اهتمامات ايش اهتمامات لغويه هذا لعبه
مختلف اوكي الابوي يقول لك انا قارئ وكاتب
جالس يستمر ما في شيء اسمه متقاعد تفضلي
فينا نذه ب الى اخر اذا عشت متردده ازاء
تحول وظيفه على مسار المهني هذا العام
ترددات طلعات نزلات لا استقرار عاطفي ازاء
فجاه وكان السحر حصل هناك اقتناع هناك
رغبه في الاستمرار في المضيف في نفس
المكان كيف نفهم هذا التقييم للوظيفه
وللمصاري الوظيفه والقرارات في نهايه
العام
جميل جدا اللي تكلمت عنه هذا اسمه
رغبه فرصه قدره يعني احيانا انه يكون
الشيء اللي جاني في البدايه يكون بغير
رغبتي انا طلب مني او امريكا
في مجال المهني في مستقبلي في هذا المكان
القدره هل انا قادره على الشيء هذا ولا لا
فلما اكتشف نفسي الواحد احيانا يحتاج يعطي
نفسه الفورصه انه يستمر لمده سنه عشان
يشوف في المواسم يشوف الفرق
يشوف الاشياء اللي تغيرت على مجال حياته
لما اخذ هذه الفرصه الجديده هل الان تغير
رقبتك ولا لا حول نظرتك غير نظرتك للامور
تتغير الامور بنظرك تحول الامر من ان انا
مجبرت او انا انطلب مني اني افعل حاجه
وانا ما كنت فيها الى شيء ست حاسه اني
مستمتعه يومي طويل اجلس مع اولادي اقدر
اروح على رياضه
تغير بعد ما اخذ صباح العربيه مثلا يعني
ههه الفكره الثانيه ههه
انه عندنا اربعه تقريبا سهام جدا
الان في المملكه من المتوسطه يطلب من
الطلاب يختاروا مسارهم الثانويه
التلاويه صعب جدا على على طفل خلينا نقول
انسان مراهق في في المتوسطه انه يختار شيء
وهو ما هو عارف كيف يكتشف نفسه هنا نقول
لهم يا جماعه تعالوا نسوي اختبارات
تعالوا نسوي سترينج فايندر عشان يكتشف
نفسه انا بدل ما ادخل تقنيه طبيه وادخل
اشتغل في همم الكريب اعمل فطاير في مول
واجلس من وظيفه اشتغل اتش ار بعدين اكتشف
لك النووي ليش التخطط هذا لما يجيك تقرير
يقول لك هذا افضل شيء يناسبك تفضل الدول
المتقدمه كلها تعمل كده طيب اذا كان
الموظف متردد ما الخيارات او ما السبيل
لكي يتخذ قرارات اكثر همم نسميها اثمار
دكتور نفسي تراد ههه جميل جدا
لانه الان زي ما قلنا الجدول اللي بنعمله
انه نحط نقيم من عشره كل رغبه من الرغبات
عندنا مثلا خلينا ناخذ المثال بشكل واضح
تقديمه الاخبار العربيه اوكي كم رغبه هيك
في صباح العربيه وكم رغبتك في الاخبار من
10 بعدين فرصتك
ممتاز الفرصه الفرصه يعني ايش المستقبل
اللي هيكون هنا في صباح العربيه او مستقبل
اني اقابل اشخاص واكون علاقات راتبي ممكن
يزيد مكانه ممكن تزيد هناك على في مجموعه
كبيره من المتحدين ومن الاشخاص هنا انا
متميزه في اكثر مكان هنا الفرصه اعطيني من
10 من 10 صباح العربيه كان من 10 اخيرا
القدره القدره ما شاء الله تبارك الله
انتم الاثنين عندكم القدره رائعه انتم في
مكانكم في ذكائكم اللغه لغوي وفي نفس
الوقت انتم ثنائي عجيب انا ماني عارف كيف
لو واحده فيك مقرره مصلحه العربيه كيف
الثانيه هتكمل
بتقول يعني حتى
التفاصيل اللي تطلع على الهواء اللي
اسمعها وانتوا تحت الهواء لما يقول بعد
قليل على صباح الارضيه وتقويله هذه
الاشياء بس
انا بسؤال يعني بشكل عام ما الاهم بالنسبه
للموظف لكي يعني يقيم نفسه في نهايه كل
عام التقدير الاداري ام رضاه عن نفسه
لنفسه شوفي هذه من اجمل الاشياء العربيه
الفكره الاسئله الخامسه هنا انا احتاج
يعني التقدير والاهتمام هذا شيء في الطريق
الناس تحب ربنا يقول النبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام يقول من لم يشكر الناس لم يشكر
الله
حتى احنا نشكر الله اول بعدين ندعي الف
كر انه انا مهما كان رضايه عن نفسي انا
احتاج اني احس انه اللي قدامي او الشخص
اللي معي يقدرني وهذه نقطه جدا هامه في
الاداره في تطوير القياده في برامج
التطوير القياده اللي بنقدمها نقول لهم لا
تتطلع تقدير من راسك تقول لها شكرا لكن
شكرا لك شكرا لك اسالني ايش اجمل تقرير
ممكن احصل عليك اسال الشخص نفسه خليه يقول
لك انا ممكن يكون التقدير بالنسبه لي
تامين طبي لاولادي وزوجتي ممكن يكون
التقي- التقدير او فلوس ممكن التقدير بكل
بساطه نادين مثلا تحتاج انه يصير اجتماع
للجماع الموظفين يا جماعه نادين خماش عملت
واحد اثنين ثلاثه
اجتماعي وتحب المكانه اعطيني الصيني زدني
يعني من هذا الشيء عشان انا احس ان
الطائره في هذا المكان زي ما كانت تدخل
بين الناس في المكان بتقول لهم ما وحشتكم
شو رايكم تحتاج هذا التغذيه العاطفيه يعني
التقدير الثانيه انت شوف نفسك هل انت راضي
عن نفسك انت مع نفسك هل انت افضل امس يعني
لا تقارن نفسك في الناس كل يوم شوف نفسك
ايش التطور الجديد اللي حصل معك نادين في
نفس النقطه احيانا نحتاج التقييمات هذه
مثلا 5 صالحني على نفسي انا عندي خمسه
نقاط قوه فيها ثلاثه في التاثير واحده في
الايجابيه واحده في الاستراتيجيه بعيده
ولا واحده منهم في التشييد منه في التمثيل
فبدل ما الوم نفسي وبدل كل ما يعني اجلد
ذاتي صرت اقول ممتاز مين يساعدني في
الجانب التنفيذي يصير تجيب مصممين اجيب
جرافيك ديزاين زي الشخص اللي جاء في تقرير
في العراق هذا انسان عنده ذكاء مصدري لا
يعمل الحديث معك يعني الوقت من زمان على
فكره بس همم كمان بدنا نشير انه انت
استعملت يعني احنا كمثال لتبسيط الصوره
للمشاهدين ونحن كنا نسال من طرفنا بشكل
عام الاسئله عامه شكرا ههه لو كل شخص لو
صار له تقريبا
نفسه ما كان يعرفها تتغير حياته جبريه
القياده والاعمال